bonaparte's restaurant is in Dire
Straits
you own a suray has sung everything into
it it's frustrating the hell out of him
at the moment because I'm going nowhere
the customers are nowhere to be seen how
he's booked non-garden nothing at all no
chances of walking perhaps swim the
kitchen's down to two staff and the
money has nearly run out
I'm going in to identify the problems
I'll find out if the Market's there how
would you pay for that
[Music]
if the team are pulling together take a
[__] penalty and if the head chef is
clued up enough
I've got just one week to turn this
restaurant into a viable business
honeymoon's over got to start making
profit now
[Music]
next to his Posh neighbors elkley and
Skipton sits salesman a little working
class town yet to make his mark on the
country map of Britain lots of fish bars
cafes quite a quaint little place little
small Yorkshire town
bonaparte's wine bar and basement
restaurant on the High Street was taken
over by its current owner just over a
year ago in her time Sue Raya sold
everything from Donkey rides to cavity
wall insulation
but the restaurant business is totally
new to her and so far the locals aren't
biting
good afternoon good afternoon Sue tears
yes
no worries so how's it going a bit
quieter today how many are you having
for lunch about two two ready that's it
and last night last night I think we did
22 again that's all
yeah unfortunately it's just died of
death
absolute death
the Stark truth is that two-thirds of
Russians don't survive past their first
birthday and as things stand Susan
danger of adding to those statistics
as a last resort she's placed all her
trust in a 21 year old head chef
together they believe that fine dining
will guarantee bonaparts a brighter
future
it's like being a nice you know what I
mean you just start from from nothing
and create something so I think that's
why I love being a chef
from a humble start five years ago
washing dishes Tim has had a meteoric
rise obviously I would like a couple of
restaurants maybe three
Bean Leeds in London New York you know
wherever just big cities you know so
that's my main ambition and obviously to
make a lot of money Tim's ultimate dream
is to become a TV chef you put parmesan
through this year but for now he's
embracing his first opportunity to run
his own kitchen
and how did you find Tim oh he found me
um he knew I'd been struggling with
chefs and lack of them and he's very
ambitious he must be [__] good if
he's a heads over 21 no either that was
a [__] good bullshitter
it's a pleasure to meet you sir likewise
and there's pleasure Lee Lee so you're
the head chef yeah
busy lunch no no absolutely not no one I
didn't think so were you standing there
twiddling your thumbs no
food takings are a dismal 200 pound a
week she should be clearing at least 10
times that but she's not even covering
Tim's wages let alone food costs on
overheads
chefs can't get excited unless there's
customers to cook for I'll never know
how good they are unless there's any
customers in the [__] restaurant
uh Tim how he's booked
non-garden nothing at all no chances of
walking perhaps
slim don't want to see you on a little
bit of pressure tonight right it's five
to six I wish you get out on the street
go knock on a few doors
and invite some locals to dinner Get
your coats on and [__] off for some
customers
if the customers won't come in off their
own free will these two young chefs are
gonna have to go and drag them in excuse
me
we'd like to invite you from uh fine
dining requires the ultimate in
presentation
surroundings and service
but most of all it requires faultless
food
you just need the people coming in now
it's like a big cake you've got all the
ingredients
you can mix it just gonna find like
consistency to make it rise
okay I'll see you there cheers the
reputation of this place can't be that
great even with free food from the fine
dining menu on offer they've only
managed to pull in 11 guests
or any head chef this would be a walk in
the park
first order two pigeon main course one
venison one bro okay where did the
tickets go
um well I just put them there because we
never really get enough to worry about
it oh [__] me that's nice who's doing
what who's doing the fish I'll do the
fish and what would you like to do
tonight uh I'll do venison I'm trying to
say is how the [__] do you organize your
kitchen oh you take care of the hot
starters I'll do the cold starters due
to the fish I'll do the meat we jump on
the pudding together then Leo's stand
there and I'll do this one and just when
when I'm not doing anything then I'll
just jump on it you know how to organize
with the first orders in now I can
really see what's going on in the
kitchen
what was that I just trashed a lot of
balls
between both in the bread first don't
you yeah
never mind fine dining they can't even
get the bread right it's [__] Frozen
get it back in the oven
is ready yes we're about to put them in
the bin because the bread's Frozen
pigeons are Coots and the [__]
Bread's not even out there
and if you toss that [__] cabbage
once more I'm gonna wrap up your ass
okay yeah
everything you turn around
even when the kitchen's busy you should
be looking to get the starters out
within 10 minutes of receiving the order
thank you very much these poor souls
have waited half an hour for the pigeon
breast with mushroom ravioli
and that's not the only problem Tim you
made her over here yes
it's burnt you don't taste that man oh
smell it then
you honestly can't taste that burnt
but now now you point it out yeah
this is really worrying a head chef who
can't even taste his own Foods burnt
he's not going to win any prizes for his
control of the kitchen either
and there's only two of them in here
the buzzing in the background that's the
veg in the microwave that should have
gone with the main cause four minutes
ago
get the [__] things out
for some an hour's weight is just too
much
desperate to keep our staff costs down
Sue has got a handful running the bar
upstairs and seems blissfully unaware of
the fast that's taking place in the
basement
kitchen is the disaster
a disaster beyond belief the blind
eating the blind
the left arm not knowing what the right
arm's doing and you want 50 60 seats
filled down there and they've got 11
customers in for dinner and up to their
eyeballs in [__] I mean real [__]
everything's going in these Cutters for
some bizarre reason they think that
Rings is the sort of ultimate fine
dining experience but it's superb I
don't understand what the hell's going
on there now I don't know all I know is
I'm not making money
I don't know what their actual weather
coming from but it's Sue's business and
she should be in charge
of the [__] mess
huh
I've ever seen such hard work for 11
guests
doesn't make you feel good does it
I've got just one week to make a
constructive impact on Bona parts
but by day two I'm clutching up straws
to find any positives to build on
Sue lack's focus and has clearly lost
control
the kitchen such a tip it's a health
hazard and worst of all the head chef
and he's made just aren't enough to
scratch I must be missing something
[Music]
um
Tim sings Edition
scallops scallops can't wait to sit
nearly every successful restaurant has a
dish that is renowned for I'm hoping
that by cooking his Tim will produce
something truly memorable something
truly worthy of a place on a fine dining
menu
signature dish which is
um scallops with uh deep fried Parmer
and black pudding sauce hollanders
certainly looks okay
you think
oh
it's got to be sick
he's only gone and given me a rancid
scallop
someone get him a drink [__]
how can you eat that if you knew they're
off why didn't you say no I didn't
I didn't know they were off
they're [__] minion
do you not taste that I do now yeah it
took a while till now
I know what it means I feel sick in the
cell now
it's um
his Grim it's [__] grim
and it's out of order
I didn't realize you were [__] off
so I suppose it's my fault early
I could kill someone
that's the bottom line
in the two days I've spent at Bonaparte
I've witnessed total incompetence in the
kitchen total lack of direction for the
management and last but not least
they've tried their best to kill me with
a rotten scallop
[__] you playing at
social well it's not about being [__]
sorry you shouldn't be in a [__]
kitchen if you don't know what's right
and what's wrong in that sense and this
is basic [__] cooking you know that
I need to check if there's any more
surprises lurking in Tim's kitchen
there's a look in here
where are they from
uh Saturday Saturday would you use them
today no
no no so what the [__] they doing in the
fridge
it looks like rabbit [__] that one it's
just some lentils oh this one's stuck to
the [__] glass it looks like sheep's
turd that's been infested with ants
we've got a [__] fur on [__]
potatoes when's that from I can't tell
you
what we do with them before I've been
throw them in bin but you keep them in
the fridge for two days before you throw
them in bed
do you see what I'm trying to get at you
yeah does it make [__] sense yes or
no no it's all this [__] fridges
jam-packed with [__] and we're standing
here saying
I'll get them in the [__] bin
this whole kitchen is disgustingly
filthy
in allowing things to Fester Tim's
putting Sue's business at risk
should we get that one cleaned out as
well yeah yes just one bad thing can
contaminate a whole fridge Tim as well
just Chuck money out the window
a health inspector would have a field
day
you know what I'm [__] gobsmacked
yeah
I got a good [__] mind to get hold of
[__] soon just tell her to [__]
close the place somewhere you know that
because this is the [__] pits you
should be ashamed
Rock Bottom I've never seen anything
like this in my entire [__] life you
know that because this is a [__]
embarrassment
to catering
let alone [__] ring down fine dining
let's move on
not a best start it could have been
weren't it to be honest [__] like
sorry I saw it out
the picture's becoming painfully clear
Tim's completely unqualified to do this
job he's blacked his way in and Sue's
been naive enough to take him on
when you do put so much like hard work
into creating stuff and then you're not
you don't use it you then you get back
so that's done like the footballers
playing with no football in it they just
run around what's playing they'll sit on
their asses after a while are they
that's how it is
all this ingredient's in there and no
customers to send it to and yet none of
them have been communicating with each
other you know that's got to go tomorrow
can we turn that into a fish pie can we
do something with it but no the blindly
in the Blind and every bloody ingredient
in that fridge
um is is money your money
Sue has no idea what's going on in their
own kitchen
key to any successful restaurant is
regular communication between management
and the head chef
I really need to get these two talking
he's not very impressed we need to keep
the place clean and everything tidy
otherwise I can be sued
in which case I'm out of business
and you're out of a job realize yeah I
know and I've had to take it on board as
well
oh yeah I just shut the sticker orange
sure I'm gonna say I told you so but
that's what you were doing
yeah fair enough she had a little dick
saw a lot of [__] you know what I mean
relations between Tim and Sue clearly
aren't healthy
Lee yeah goggles gloves before we do any
[__] cooking in here now I want the
place absolutely spotless goggles on
please that's it show me you handsome
bastard
it's not just the kitchen as I thought
here any clue depression turn knows it's
damn stupid to attempt fine dining in a
basement let alone one that's beneath a
busy bar
[Music]
Sue's Panic is obvious when you see the
weird mix of fine dining menus and
Scrappy handwritten boards advertising
TV name cabarets
bonaparte's image has clearly confused
potential customers she was trying to
think to do too many things to be all
things to all people so she was turned
to have you know live music and have an
internet cafe
and uh also the impression that you got
when you came in was she'd be shuffling
around in her leggings and her slippers
she's gonna trap the people that she
wants to attract
it's not as nice as the one that's
something to cross the road
[Music]
the newly opened competition just 200
yards away has been fully booked since
it opened so the pandas are definitely
out there
find a clear identity for Bonaparte and
make a clean start
Valentine's nine is just four days away
it's one of the most important nights of
the wrestling calendar and it can make
or break a new venture
if we're going to reinvent bonaparte's
image we've got to do it now
but we'll soon accept the DraStic change
of Direction I'm about to propose
it's clearly
not going to work as a fine dining
experience does Tim know how much
pressure you're under financially I say
flippantly you know I'll end up going
bankrupt if you're not careful but
doesn't realize how true that is yeah I
mean how close I
in real terms in real terms
um probably
I've got probably three months
maximum Jesus you know I'm willing to
take constructive criticism and it's not
working is it otherwise we'd have more
people in the basics are wrong I mean
the basics are so so wrong and it's you
know it's embarrassing it's going to go
back to comfort rustic
easy going food it's going to become
more of a bistro because the place oozes
that kind of style
I know Sue's convinced but if I'm to
flush out Tim's pretensions to fine
dining once and for all I need to
provide him with evidence that he can't
fail to take on board
gentlemen Tim
Scholars
olives your sauce and a bit of deep
fried parmesan it looks like potato but
I'm not sure first time you had a
scallop
and this is a beef and Ale pie
CE
yeah beautiful the scallops and the
black pudding and the Parma ham how much
do you pay for that
well I don't know scroll up to date
anyway so 850 850.
and what would you pay for the pie
but eight pounds
7.95. an 8.95 well done
which one would you prefer well I like
the pie personally well I like the meat
I'm definitely thank you gentlemen thank
you one nail you [__]
Tim needs to learn a few basic Russian
rules
if you don't know your Market you'll
never get bums on seats I would probably
go with this one too [__] nil next
please we've got two seconds here's
another one have you got two seconds
Russians without customers will go bust
yeah
excuse me
put another way Tim needs to start
producing food the people of silson
won't be able to resist that is gorgeous
you wouldn't pay 8.95 for that in the
major cities yeah I'd expect to but that
is very very reasonable and delicious
are you listening I am listening Bistro
that's where we're going yeah fine
dining
laughs
who's going in for it
it's not bad news you know that it's
[__] good news yeah and it's it's
it's clear
the writing's on the wall
she's come to the end of the hotel up
there that's pretty obvious that yeah
she's she's had enough fun yeah is that
clear yeah it's clear yeah and you know
you're [__] cocky with her you know
that yeah yeah and she pays your [__]
salary are you mad how much have you put
in here
yeah not a [__] penny
not a single penny but you've taken from
haven't you yeah so now it's time to
give back absolutely definitely and not
cooking for egos get rid of it Back to
Basics you know that what I want you two
to do just to confirm that you do know
the basics both at the same time cook me
a [__] omelette show me something
that I can eat
and be happy with
anomaly is probably one of the first
things you learn to cook at catering
College
what was the last time before
I've learned I've never cooked an
omelette before oh don't be stupid I
haven't
let's look inside
what does that telly
um
slightly overcooked slightly it tastes
like [__] rubber I'm both overcooked
that was [__] by any standard
you're a head chef
you're taking the piss you know that
you are taking the piss you know that
yes got it
gives you nothing back
and the whole idea of telling him off is
to sort of help train him and educate
him but
clearly
not used to being told what to do
right make me another omelette [__] it
let's go
any chef worthy Soul should be able to
Source good quality ingredients at a
good price
the locals really think bonaparts is too
expensive they want value for money for
Sue to start making any sort of profit
Tim Needs To Be Clever about what he
buys
I have two rare back in sandwiches
please and two cups of tea
he needs to wake up to the real world
clearly in need of some inspiration for
his new Bistro style menu thanks darling
thank you that's you're all on that one
and spending on those new trainers
really ah try not to the Chinese tongues
tonight we've got a table of four in on
you okay to buy starter main course and
pudding 20 quid 5 quid per head right
they want to see how clever you are with
that money right
[Music]
all right we're making some french onion
soup today so uh we're looking for some
like sort of rustic like baguettes
[Music]
can have a look at that clearly Tim's
never bought anything from a market
before in his life
discount for the trade any discount for
the trade
it's always worth buying before you know
that someone you're on the telephone in
the morning you're checking your
suppliers and you want to know how much
the fish is you can always bargain with
them I bet you don't seize money this
way do you
I will do it from now on [__] right
you will
Tim's menus are packed with expensive
fish and meat cuts he needs to open his
eyes to the tasty less expensive options
on offer yeah what's that next to the
pig's head
why is that there
um
that's oxtail oxtail you ever used
oxtail before no what would you do with
a braising steak
oh really maybe a barbecue quite nice on
barbecue you know and when she gets them
raising State means [__] braze it so
it's telling you what to do with it so
what would you do with it where is it
like a stew I can't put that on the
[__] barbecue just looking for some
chicken breasts
yes there you go look we've shown you
it's nice check it let's have a look
how much is chicken per breast
it's a lot less than I get it from my
book Joe is it your butcher's more
expensive yeah cheese four of them
please any uh discount for trade it's
careful trade how much was it four four
That's my boy for me cheers I have a
bill please uh a receipt with the 80
with ERT
you'd come again yeah absolutely the
more they see you the more Fanta you
have with them the more buggers you get
with them and the cheaper it becomes
yellow yeah
then the Russian starts to make a bit of
[__] money yeah
get the picture yeah I get it thanks
[__] for that
how much do we spend just over 12 quid
12 quid fantastic for four portions
brilliant okay french onion soup it
costs 75 Pence to make a portion okay
how much did you go on the menu for
your times it by four and that should
cover everything 295 for a bowl of soup
and we've made money on that and one
thing we're not going to do with the
ingredients we bought this morning is
waste anything we waste nothing
with the Valentines it's Extravaganza
just two days away I'm under no
Illusions as to what we're up against
[__] lit dick in the kitchen you know
that go get some [__] energy [__]
21 for God's sake you should be getting
[__] 12 hard-ons a day not one a
[__] month let's go Lee's got a bit
of mouse we've got to hold Tim's hand
every step of the way are you sure you
want to be a chef yes you are yeah in
right into the center this is our one
chance to see if Tim can cope with his
new Bistro style food I'm gonna turn the
knife out put it back in and bring it to
the
Edge there yeah yeah
gently gently gently make love to it
then [__] it
outside leaves okay what do we do with
them you throw them away yeah we usually
throw them away yeah
but before we let them loose on the
paying customers I've asked them to cook
for four special people in the privacy
of their own home what I haven't told
him is for his own family
you'd like to stir it into it no you
leave it dangling on top so it gets
perfect of course you let it [__]
stir inside we've got soup chicken lemon
meringue pie yeah
let's go to surprise Mom and Dad shall
we let's go around to the house and you
cook their tea okay Korea sauce for the
chicken
um
I'm asking you yeah I I don't I don't
think so good because the Centos is the
sauce the garlic sauce okay now
yeah we don't need a zoo we don't need
any shoe
hello Madge how are you surprise I hate
to use Tim's folks as guinea pigs but
with the three-course meal already
prepared all Tim needs to do is reheat
the soup and cook the kievs
this should be a walkover even for him
there you go
Break Me song
it was always in the kitchen as a boy
wanting to help bake because he loves
talking about it doesn't he yes yeah but
then he decided whilst he was at school
that that's what he wanted to do and he
got himself a job in the kitchen and it
just went on from there told me that he
was going to be a chef and he was going
to the good food show to meet Gary
Rhodes and off he went fantastic look
what's happened yeah
oh
burn it
burn it here we go
so I'll keep you waiting that's quite
all right he's ready
let's not forget Tim is a head chef
where's my plans
don't forget your croutons
ladies first
this is so French onion soup
minus the croutons what we're going to
do with this number
oh look at that
superb torched on the outside and pink
in the middle as for the lemon meringue
pie you'll get a better reception if you
threw it out
Tim family wouldn't dream of criticizing
him but the paying customers on
Valentine's night won't be as forgiving
and you [__] it before
what chance have you got for 44
I'm now starting to [__] myself
it's my fourth day at bonaparts Tim's
first attempt at cooking a simplified
Bistro meal may have impressed his
granny but he and I both know The Awful
Truth
it was a spectacular flop
you paid as a head chef aren't you yeah
do you think you should be a head chef
not really I think [__] for that
don't start crying I'm not well you look
you're about to [__] bubble
okay so you're delighted with that
bookings for tomorrow night Valentine's
Cabaret are piling in
with the restaurant nearly booked to
capacity I'm trying my hardest to stay
positive that's fine Mr Lowe I'm sure
you'll enjoy it
but with just a day to go it'll take
more than high energy drinks for these
two to pull it off
when someone's been told off the first
thing you do in a kitchen is come back
at 100 mile an hour and
this guy disintegrates every time you
tell me something he just disappears
it's Oblivion
and loses all sense of concentration
that little short span that he has why
don't we swap the rolls around tomorrow
why don't you become the sous chef and
Lee becomes the head chef for tomorrow
night
no answer
whatever you want to do guys it's your
[__] kitchen
you're supposed to say bollocks no I'm
the [__] Chef my name's Tim Grant
it's me on the menu no
yeah
yes or no yes
maybe it's me I should try the softly
softly approach
we've got a big night Saturday night
it's full I think the first time since
you've both been here that the place is
full okay and whilst I'm here you're not
shafting me as well at the same time you
know that yeah we're gonna work together
over the next 15-20 minutes I want you
both to think of something really simple
menu wise three starters three main
courses and three puddings what do you
think Lee soup
Yeah by passing some of the decision
making back to Tim I'm hoping to build
up his confidence and install some pride
in his food it's hard to write a simple
menu when you've had your head up your
ass for so long doing trying to make
fancy silly food that's the kind of
stuff we're going for in it so what I
think about it land classes liver and
onions mashed potato macaroni cheese
fish and chips mushroom peas lamb shot
what language that sounds nice and you
come with the ideas together yeah we'll
just flip through some books and thought
what simple and um you know I basically
thought what did we used to have at
school what did we like at school and
not forgetting where are we we're in
Yorkshire
[Music]
in devising this new menu I'm aiming to
take most of the pressure off Tim and
Lee during service 90 of the food can be
prepared and perfected a day in advance
that's good see if you show me you can
handle two plans at once as long as it's
made well they can't fail to be a hit
with the customers
there should be 15 things going on there
all the same time coordination
understanding medium pink is it Well
Done onions roasted Bang
in short bonaparte's new Bistro menu is
designed to be idiot proof yeah
definitely identify them as vegetarians
yeah let's go
so far Tim's attitude towards soon has
been that of a stroppy teenager rather
than a respectful and supportive
employee I'm gonna go on a tomato soup a
rustic tomato soup yeah yeah some little
uh cheese that's probably a first is
actually come to us I've had to run down
and Chase all the time then I need this
I'm like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah it'll
come later I said I need it now
basically you just put them through some
butter
today seems a lot better don't know what
he's been doing to him down there but
he's certainly improving
and the week I've been here I've hardly
seen Tim Orly sample or season anything
they've made
no wonder their tasteless food is
failing to ruin the customers everything
we do in this kitchen has to be tasted I
don't care if it's a [__] bread roll
a lemon meringue pie or chicken kiev you
have got to start tasting things
from now on bland is off the menu and to
teach these to a lesson they'll never
forget I'm resorting to dirty tactics
you know what a medium steak tastes like
yes
Does that taste like a sirloin T-bone
steak or is it a rump steak
sirloin sirloin
it tastes like solo [__] you know here
we go
open up
okay tell me whether it's medium or is
that well done medium and well done none
of you got that right
yes yes
oh
pork and [__] lamb [__] now you
don't you don't realize until someone
blindfold you and feeds you that your
palate so
non-active
could have been worse
could have been chicken it wouldn't look
like [__] idiots
oh [__]
Tim's had a week of non-stop grief from
me
put the ball down this boy has really
tested my patience all right how do we
know they're ready now
you can lift them upside down yeah there
you go and I really don't know if any of
it sunk in
what I'd love to do is
but with more than 40 guests expected in
just over two hours time he'll soon be
tested to his absolute limits
no no don't tell me it was the mud
I can't even take a [__] penalty I'll
say this for Tim he's no quitter and I
don't want to see him fail but now he's
got to prove he's master of his own
kitchen we're not leaving this as a draw
you know that
hey been cooking nobody draws ever one
thing's for sure tonight he'll either
sink or swim
another two upstairs
possibly okay good news good news
another two so we're up to 50 48 now
Sue's never had so many bookings she's
having to move furniture out to fit more
tables in
you're happy with that
chicken kiev with roasted van Tomatoes
T-Bone stay with homemade chips because
there's so many involved for dinner I
wouldn't stall them upstairs for too
long you're really going to dump Us in
it big time Pro cocktail three bean
salad with mustard dressing what do you
think
[Music]
I hardly dare say it but this place has
got a real Buzz about it
there's one thing missing what do you
like on all your menus
we should put that on the back or my
name on it we'll work as a team and it's
a giant effort and Bistro you know
that's it that's the most sensible thing
you said to me all [__] week you know
that
thank you
every decent restaurant in the country
is full on Valentine's night
the competition down the road is packed
to the rafters
and for once so is bone apart
in a small town like salesman business
thrives on Word of Mouth
and if tonight's a disaster it could
break soon I have got to feel that it
will not be able to cope with the
numbers especially when he's saying that
11's busy I don't think so
so we'll see what he's made of
Tim has got to get this right okay
six o'clock first orders in
Chef yes well whatever to Scott Scott
first order in
hey are we going to let the kitchen
border call out the tickets or are you
going to call them out come on on order
two soup two chicken one creme brulee
one tree called tart let's go super
smade get on to boil
Scotty put some water in it please
something's burning what's that burning
it's just something yeah it's on the
grill thing it's not the croutons eh no
it's not the crew one don't burn the
croutons
your soup's on you yeah hang on for the
chicken not yet I think we should put
the pan on first yeah start the chicken
and as they're eating the soup the
chicken's cooking it
are you all right yeah yeah first order
in it's upstairs you're okay well it
depends on for the chicken yeah
don't burn the croutons
[Music]
all right how long for that soup
Typecast 45 seconds
oh [__] off look at you hey what the
[__] are you doing either way
young man
what are you doing
slow down talk to him
Lee can you send the two soup please
wait
look at the croutons
charcoal again
oh God it's the first [__] order
nothing no well you you're cooking like
an absolute [__] you know that yeah just
take your time
big deep breath and talk to Lee a little
bit you're just on your own spinning
around round and round and just creating
a [__] Bedlam yeah calm down get
yourself organized yes and control
yourself now [__] come back to me a
little bit come back to me a bit yes
come on Timmy Fresh Start or we're gonna
go down like a sack of [__]
that's better Lee look at him look hey
nice and bright give us a smile
it's well done isn't it yeah yeah come
on in teamwork
two minutes for some eventually
this guy can have two ovals out of there
mate please
on order three prong cocktail one soup
and one sirloin medium one Tebow medium
one sirloin medium so don't rush the
Stars got a lot of stuff to get on here
communication
enough
[Music]
yeah yeah
oh no one prawns one beans one Kia one
sirloin well done one lemon one Brew
layer
all right Scotty to what we can have two
ovals on me please
now now you're talking to the team which
is fantastic you keep it going yes
and then you stop talking
we're gonna go we're gonna go down yeah
hey it's not quite right but at least
it's moving yeah
medium with salad that's a medium on
itself without salad and that's a rare
yeah we out sell it
keep it together yeah yeah yeah let's
not get nervy food was was excellent
yeah very enjoyable that's what we
expected to have really it's a really
tasty um really enjoyable it's nice how
many more to come please Sue uh there's
another four four I have a book actually
the local competition tonight it's got
46 books if we do this last four we've
been them no
[Music]
cool service please uh Scotty
one T-bone steak medium and one chicken
kiev please and that's all I'm going to
the table
um
when it's brownies cooked when it's
black it's [__]
what's the pastries please
[Music]
two sirloin for medium not finished yet
but yeah well done
Tim's ground and grander are celebrating
their 44th wedding anniversary
[Music]
at last Tim can repay them for the
rubbish he served up a couple of nights
ago with a delicious welcome meal
it was lovely it was beautiful
[Music]
did it yeah yeah memories
do you really surprise me tonight and
I'm really seriously over the moon that
you didn't [__] it I'm serious huh yeah
because the first 15 minutes of six
o'clock you're acting like the biggest
[__] in Britain you know that all over
the shop and you pulled it back together
and that wasn't me that was you
and the feedback from them out there has
been brilliant what does that tell you
what does that what does that put in
there another service like that for a
long time and these stupid [__]
illusions of grandeur all this stupid
fine dining crap that you're trying to
do it's gone do you understand yeah
exactly where you are now yeah yeah
totally understand do you understand
what you're capable of doing within this
restaurant yes yes stop trying to take
it Beyond something it's never going to
be you'll [__] the restaurant and you'll
[__] yourself
big time to never forget tonight it's up
to you now not to allow it to go back to
where it was I'd be too soft you have to
be yes I'm glad you're saying yeah
and I've also
um
allowed him to have his hint too I also
think you've been confused to what you
want because you haven't been focused on
One Direction for the restaurant because
you've been you know jumping and that's
part of a panic yeah and that's wrong
and now tonight clearly evident exactly
what you need to do from this day
onwards and if he changes anything I'll
pickle these nuts
when I arrived at Bonaparte a month ago
it literally had no customers
head chef Tim gray was a liability
well I didn't realize you were [__]
off he couldn't even cook an omelet
you're taking the picture you know that
in one grueling week we transformed
Bonaparte from a failing fine dining
restaurant into a buzzing Bistro
with Tim sending out quality food to
nearly 50 contented customers on
Valentine's night
[Music]
yeah
but since I left Sue's given Tim two
written warnings over his attitude
now I'm back unannounced to find out
what is going on
turn that [__] thing off my God
what's going on
chilling chilling it's Friday night it's
7 30. how many books four four and
you've got the music blaring away yeah
I'm just Wesley he's upstairs I'm back
he's in the bar what the [__] is that in
there
you're not serving them are you yeah
what the fridge is like
oh my God I'm like what is that [__] in
there
there's mold and fur
dear oh dear so you haven't changed have
you oh [__] you now a whole week
drumming into their thick skulls and it
comes to this holy [__]
nobody in this place is taking control
and in this state a health inspector
would close them down without a second
thought
so I've got to show you this because as
far as your responsibility and this is
your Gaff there you go should not be in
you didn't see this see no I didn't
touch that In fairness to tell me it was
doing okay it seemed to be okay for the
first three days and then it went no
this is not right this is this is
[__] miles away this is a nightmare
you know that because it's more loss on
top of more loss and more loss and more
mold
that's what worries me because you need
to touch that you need to rub your
finger on that you need to go to a chip
you need to season something you put
your finger in this tomato soup and then
they're all [__] you've just
contaminated the whole place and that's
what really worries me this kitchen is
not fit to cook a [__] thing in right
now
and that's your problem
I think I better just close
and put due to refurbishment
and you should bet our grade three you
know
it's been giving him another chance and
another chance
so that's I can't tolerate that it's
just going to end up
professional suicide isn't it
it's commonly simple as that I don't
honestly think
he did it deliberately I don't think
he's an enough to he said well I just
think he lives in a Walter Mitty world I
begin to think that he's just convinced
himself to be honest
to go from
Valentine's Day evening to this is
it's not even funny there's just
something wrong with it it really is
well Valentine's Day are good man I
don't think I've gone home to bed or
whatever feeling in a better happier
State of Mind
and tonight I don't think I could go to
bed in a worse one
it's beyond recognition really anyhow
[__] stupid that
someone can be you know what I mean
dog one
and who is that someone to oh that'll be
me
pretty much
yeah
well at least the bar's busy that is one
Saving Grace but really thank God she
closed that kitchen down because it was
[__] disgusting I mean really
appallingly bad
shockingly bad
I will get in on me you're fine I will
respecting you and giving it all the
like gentlemanly bloody stuff I could do
and then you went and shot it out
[__] pan no don't put it on me if a
floor is still fixed before it doesn't
matter anymore well it was filthy does
it matter yes I think it does I think
we've established that look yeah it's
not the [__] flower that's worse
[Applause]
all right
people dream of owning a restaurant in a
quaint town like this set in beautiful
countryside cooking fresh local produce
serving loyal locals as well as the
tourists
a Russian to die for surely
but the glass house is in deep trouble
[Music]
[__] all right do our hotel yeah
the kitchen's in chaos and the customers
are Mighty unimpressed it was rare that
the half was just about a boxing in the
center and it was really disappointing
is losing money like there's no tomorrow
and the owner's about to crack up I'd
rather not be here I'd burn the bloody
place down
you know better not put that on camera
he's got his wits in so he's called me
in to turn it around I've got just one
week to do it and that's a tall order
garlic popcorn I will save Neil's
restaurant I won't tolerate excuses last
night you had bad breath no hiding place
and no [__] upstairs
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
not allowed to sometimes do Neil Farrell
has always dreamed of owning a
restaurant but in three years since he
bought the Glass House his dream has
turned into a nightmare
he's deep in debt so many people are
after him for money and he's turned his
mobile phone off
he could go mad and he may even go bust
when it's your own place and he should
earn money and you're you're the one
that's you know Walking the Tightrope
it's it's very it's very different and
that's my problem that we haven't we
haven't worked out which road we're
taking at least he's had the sense to
call me in for help but if Neil's going
to pull this one out of the fire he's
got to take some tough decisions I can't
do that for him but of course I can
encourage him first stop the kitchen to
see if the chef know what they're doing
the hf-37 like me he trained at
clarity's before my time he's on 25
Grand a year so he'd better be good
about the same amount as you did the
other day
until he says I can call him Gordon he's
Mr Ramsey
he thinks that there might be some
confusion with Harry ramsden's
first I need to watch him cook and see
how he runs his kitchen everyone's
nervous that they get to call him Mr
ramsden
morning
Mr Ramsay extremely pleased to meet you
likewise first name Richard Richard
where do you think is going wrong it's a
very difficult question we've been a bit
of heads against
many a time what we're doing wrong
should we turn it into a pizzeria is
that what people want
you just got to the stage now where
I just feel it ain't working and I'm
questioning my ability
to control his team and Inspire them the
headshots Got to Believe In himself
otherwise forget it
Jack sees a salad battered salmon
hello
not a Dicky bird no one even answers the
head chef
no no we Chef no nothing I have to ask
for it oh you have to ask for it nine
times out of ten great you're not lost
the words though
oh
time to test Richard's cooking I thought
would be nice thing to do um just for
today for to go upstairs and have a
quick bite to eat for yourself just in
your hands you're gonna you're gonna
you're gonna cook for me
you choose your favorites your
Specialties yeah I want three dot cake
putting in he's not having those he's
having four fresh ones of which he's
gonna eat too
Richard's proud of his duck cakes with
chili jam exotic no pretentious crap
I hear about Scotch eggs
when someone's been very lazy in the
kitchen
because I've got a bloody bone
same
I'll say that one for later
another his favorite combos braised lamb
shank with parsnip crisps it's very
clumsy clumsy cooking and lazy elements
the oils on these stink
but it has been changed about three or
four weeks
the whole meal would set you back nearly
30 quid way too much
hey guys
[Music]
food was disappointing sadly I did choke
obviously saw the law but that was stuck
at the back of my throat but however you
know I'm glad it was me not a pain
customer a restaurant owner's best
investment will always be in the chef
and if you haven't got that sort of
major asset downstairs in the kitchen
and forget it the guy's going to be a
motivator he's going to be a leader he's
going to make you money he's going to
bring customers back and clearly from
what I've seen so far Neil hasn't got
that in Richard that's pretty obvious
foreign
to see how Richard runs his Brigade on a
busy night good head chefs get the best
out that team no matter what
Ian was a waiter but got bored serving
food so now he's trying to cook it
instead
Ian's girlfriend Claire only works here
part-time as a main job is running a
Bookshop I suspect she's only here
because she's going out with Ian we've
got wild animals I didn't nibble about
it but nothing
Randall the kitchen Porter things are
related because we're both from Scotland
[Music]
Craig crazy in year two at catering
College he looks pretty clueless to me
but let's hope he proved me wrong
team will always turn out good food
whatever the pressure
it's one of the busiest nights of the
Year Saturday at half term so it's a
perfect test
what is that
that's it there are 106 customers built
if they're happy they'll spend an
average of 30 foot each plus wine and
The Glass House will take over four
grand
but their biggest problem is coping with
lots of orders
don't Fox upstairs are up that's what
your ass is a second [__] call away
from non-existent table as well
Neil did tell me when the pressure's
intense the kitchen collapses into chaos
you know what it's true
he ends up giving meals away things soon
go from bad to very ugly no it's not
[__] all right do our hotel yeah
[Music]
it's horrible it hasn't been trimmed
that's exactly what it is yeah take it
to Richard's Jay get on the phone now
find out where this fish was going
the whole thing's gone pear-shaped
everyone's running around like headless
chickens
um I off the ball and um just a massive
breakdown in communication [__]
Partridge
I need a bigger piece of sea bass doing
you decide or the what's going on need
to come back and that needs to be cooked
some more do you want this [__] party
right for [__] sake I need another
partridge
we've just been reading the right chat
it's really grim
apology Chef 36 I've had that stuff
we've had the order in 40 minutes yes
so it's not good enough
where's that big
picture
[Music]
[__] buy it off me mate and you'll do
me the biggest [__] favor
you could
I think someone's about to pisses pants
I think it's just gone there
[Music]
I've been at the Glass House restaurant
in Ambleside for just a day from what
I've seen so far it's going to be bloody
hard to turn this place around in a week
a month possibly but now it's in quest
time there's no question where to start
that cocky chef
11 chips
it was going well
huh ten past nine that went outside
um have a quick chat with customers and
all of a sudden I started seeing this
food coming back huh where do you think
it broke down
[Music]
the guys propped me but the guys just
[__] let go as normal
[__] chaotic say every [__]
Saturday we've ever done
it's exactly the same maybe I just
shouldn't give a [__] maybe I should
just say [__] you give us your money
thanks very much then it wouldn't bother
me and I could go home and it wouldn't
matter if I've got a [__] restaurant
because there's loads of them out there
and the owners are driving around in
bloody Porsches I'm driving a shitty
Astro van and I'm [__] close to tears
do you know what I think Neil would
rather throw himself in Lake Windermere
then actually turn around and be the bad
guy with his staff
it's not all kitchens full but um you
know the kitchen's the engine room yeah
yeah hi Richard
yeah if we're not firing all pistons and
we're not you know on the ball
right
the chef's answering your question
what was the question question was what
happened to 20 past nine where did we go
we were [__] Motoring
shite
well at least have the bullets to
apologize to yeah he's standing there
blowing his [__] eyes out
yeah take your [__] hat off
we've hit rock bottom
let me get upset
huh hey
I'm telling you I don't want to get
upset the team will need a real boost if
we want to get back on track
it's all going so [__] well but
there's still some problems to tackle
it's my second day in the late District
trying to save the Glass House
restaurant and I tell you what is an
uphill struggle
[Music]
next battle hygiene this place is about
as clean as a puppy's litter tray
the secret film was taken last week they
knew I'd sent someone to check around
but they didn't know it was marked
Sergeant my head chef at claridge's
and they didn't know he had a camera
hidden in his hat
plastic containers they instantly tell
me the food's not as fresh as they
should be even Chef's not sure rather
even me mate
this kitchen is filthy straight from a
dirty floor into the pesto it's supposed
to be a kitchen not a building site
let's go cheers
the cardinal rule of cooking your
kitchen must be clean and by clean I
mean spotless
the normal clean damage is what every
Saturday night after service
but you must have one big clean and
weakness
Randall don't [__] it's not [__]
the last thing I want to do is look up
end of the night make time
clean kitchen clean food
lazy kitchen Porter p45
Randall
but it's not just up to the kitchen
Porter everyone should be responsible
but they're not
you've got to trust the Brigade that you
pay and secondly and you know bring them
on evolve them make them talented yeah
keeping hold of them motivating them
um evolving them increasing the
responsibilities working on them let me
think how much time we spend to go in
the kitchen all day long yeah
it's exactly that what we spent it's the
first time if we spend more time to go
in the kitchen than we do at home we
have Bloody families
nothing more I can do until they finish
time for Neil I do wish you'd turn on
his mobile phone grow some bollocks and
act like a bloody boss
there are too many customers to cope
with on Saturday nights but the rest of
the week the place is deserted that's
partly because no one can find it
when I walk past for the first time
coming down here from the right hand
side I had no idea where the restaurant
was yeah and here we should have a nice
prominent sign Glass House restaurant
with a menu board beautifully lit and
whether you want to put some little
bloody neon lights or nice fancy lights
around it is an attraction right and and
that Lit see that sign there The Glass
House yeah and with a new logo and the
new printing just something that you
know
um speaks value right yeah
um because it looks it looks too
complicated it doesn't even say about a
restaurant it doesn't say you're a
Russian though exactly I want to see a
bloody telephone number on there see the
salad
um Doug cakes now for the menu a
well-written menu should entice Customs
inside at best this one is confusing at
worst it's just bizarre I don't want to
read popcorn guys popcorn where the [__]
did that come from
so something the vegetarians always say
that they've got no there's no crunch or
no body in any of the dishes they've got
no palette
yes for God's sake vegetarianism is on
the decline
um lunch menu two starters two main
courses and two puddings
yeah I'm just wondering how many people
are going to come in for a two course
lunch yeah
um we're gonna look at the menus the two
course and if it's hearty rustic country
fried food then trust me because I know
you don't want to let go of the sandwich
and I totally understand I want to let
go I just don't want to let go of the
revenue I serve sandwiches I got no
problem serving a lobster roll sucking a
pig sandwich yeah I've got no problem a
beautiful um beef sandwich I've got no
problem serving sandwiches whatsoever
okay guys great yeah open mackerel
sandwich
work down good man like the seasons with
a team kitchen we can improve the food
and I can find out exactly how the team
works
time flowers
generally not because they're very very
fine and then Craig yeah yeah taste it
there's your spoon Craig looks scared
stiff making a mistake you'll have to
change that if you want to be a chef
yeah
so we've got no color on it
two more around the outside one in the
center Ian's got some bad habits but
he's only been cooking for three months
I think he may make it one day
the whole thing's changing color and it
gets halfway what does that mean turn it
over exactly but we're just going to
finish on the bottom okay good good
question
you're a very very good cook
yeah I don't know anyone ever told you
that before
this restaurant is going to be better
than the BLT yeah up
and over good Amanda how's your sandwich
like a cat that's got the cream in here
you know
different from a BLT that's better than
a BLT yeah not as good as a big one
[Laughter]
you know that okay
in a well-run kitchen everyone makes a
contribution but Richard hasn't even
asked his team what they think the
problems are
Craig what's your weak point in the
kitchen
it's when I get a lot of orders on I I
don't have them in front of me so I I
get to get shouted out once and then I
have to probably check the ticket again
put it together in your own mind then
just jot it down Saturday night's quite
hard when all the checks are coming on
and I do kind of lose where I'm at and
how many Stakes I've got on order and
how many
but when it goes quiet it's kind of like
it's difficult to motivate yourself it's
difficult yeah
is that your third one it's like the
second one Jesus
Nails finally agreed to a new lunch menu
simple fresh food for a tenner including
the new mackerel
sandwiches
I'm glad you enjoyed it at last some
happy customers we've got a restaurant
full of happy people fantastic chive
small amount Ian
treat it with a bit of love and care
place it in there gently yeah and you
don't throw it in
[Music]
I got the kitchen suddenly sounds if
it's running well if I want salmon one
sausage yeah
random sweep the floor please
flour everywhere yeah and I didn't see
you do it anyway what time was that
what time was that
um
let's go nicely there you go play can
you let me know when that Brandy's
package was three minutes
within 30 seconds every section of the
kitchen's talking to one another
good
morning
everyone in the team's responding but
rich is not working with them he wanted
to help you
[Music]
it's not really that busy I just wanted
to see us working together even more now
I know there's nothing for you to do
right now but
yeah I know it's painful but get him
doing something for you please yeah
thank you
and you hey oh
ask him can we do anything for you
Richard yeah what do you need doing okay
so this is where are they mashed ready
we saw this walking to do yeah together
even Richard said to me the guy that's
got no man management skills he's been
watching you and the way you are with
the guys and you're bringing out the
best in them yeah you're bringing out
the hunger that's what you're paying 25
Grand a year for I know I'm not so I'm
not being funny or pressing around with
25 Grand a year but I've been stupid
with them I've been cradling them my
head was too far up my bloody ass to
realize what the hell was going on
Neil needs to get his head out of his
house and focus on his job keeping
customers happy and making sure they
spend their money The Roasting pepper
and tomatoes he needs his customers to
bypass the cheap early supper menu that
runs until 7 30 and eat a la carte and
that's how he'll pay off his debts and
rebuild his reputation
let me just tell you something 15
portions of Apple okay 15 portions of
fondant and 15 portions of bloody grass
and dolphin Wars five nights a week is
125 000 pound a year turnover hey on
three items out of nearly 20 on a menu
yeah
we just arrived said they're early 15
minutes early so I want to make sure
that Neil doesn't give them the early
supper menu because we're going to find
out whether or not they're here for a
bargain or not I don't want to sell the
a la carte not the Cheapo menu
they look like they've got a bit of
money
now you've got two menus on today you've
got the a la carte menu we've also got
the early supper menu
and so you've got lots to choose from
that table was the arrived we said they
were really early 20 minutes early
they're booked at 7 30. so therefore
don't give them the cheap menu
the table of four yeah just sat down
right what did you give them again
will he never learn
Neil must work the tables not worry
about the kitchen if you only focused
you did a fine job do you know what you
are a phenomenal salesman you got the
most amazing wine seller
you can take an order you can take an
order and you can clean it on the wine
and the better the food the more money
they're going to spend on wine
after three days things are looking up
the guys upstairs are starting to get
the basics but my big worry is the
kitchen Richard just isn't earning is 25
Grand I'm really sorry for saying it but
the guy showed no form of information so
if he's not inspired
these young guys they've got to dwindle
away make sure Little Kingdom yeah
control it
it's the biggest problem in the glass
house but Neil just won't face the facts
I'm gonna have to show him how well the
kitchen can run without his head chef
don't take this wrong way but I want you
to take the night off tonight
and I want you to take the night off now
I love both you
to have dinner together
yes
yes you are when was last time you guys
had dinner together truthfully without
any [__]
five and a half years ago two and a half
years ago hello two and a half years ago
and when was the last time you sat in it
here
no never done it we do it
yeah we can do it thank you there's only
one condition that this takes place the
kitchen downstairs don't know about it
and I need a bit of support from you
guys as well yeah because it'd be too
exciting
I've seen Richard home the team may not
be up to this and if it goes wrong I may
look alright tosser yeah yeah we have an
absolute Nightmare Night last night I
left you together for two hours and it
was the biggest
you're on the hot plate you're gonna be
running the kitchen okay and then if
it's going really well I want you to run
the kitchen for half an hour and God
forbid if it is going that well yeah
scratch your head scratch your bollocks
I'm not interested I want you to run the
kitchen yeah for half an hour yeah right
maybe from 1 30 to 2 o'clock in the
morning I don't know yet let's just
really work for each other yeah let's
not lose the plot and let's show him
your Chef that you guys
are more talented than he believes you
are yeah okay
why don't you host the meeting
yeah 30 seconds yeah that's good right
me I'm shutting up okay you host the
meeting you call the shots right
got some pumpkin pumpkin soup yeah it's
on your section fish pie with peas
we've got 12 and we've got one more
downstairs and he'd be 13. shuffling Pig
how long comes out in the oven about
eight minutes okay that's fine cake yep
sorry pretty good okay really well done
yeah a little panel back not a little
kiss though it's perfect
yes
ready yeah
table 37 has arrived and it's gone 7 30
so they'll definitely get the a la carte
menu
cheers mate
hi cheers Cocker I can only pray that
Neil tastes the difference in the food
then over a nice glass of wine you can
give Richard what for
eign think about what you're doing don't
rush it Craig
what do you do
labeling this tub how about looking at
the food and show a little bit of
Interest what you're doing okay
P leads on a little bit asparagus and
just blaze that round
[Music]
if you don't eat that soon mate I am
told you about a sexual experience
downstairs in the kitchen for the last
three four days
well done okay
let's send it Randall don't send it
yes watch that thank you thank you well
done thank you good good good good I'm
feeling good Brenda away table 34 please
when he's gone are you going to be able
to instill what he's in still it is now
in charge of the kitchen everybody
okay
[Music]
you've got to sustain it now forever do
you know what I mean I am [__]
myself
to produce this food I am really really
[__] scared but
I'll Die Trying
a lot better than last night so far yeah
also yeah
um is that not because
Richard's not here
I'm not gonna say anything what are you
not going to say we won't have a job
let me ask you you've got a pair of
bollocks has it gone well without
Richard
it's gone smooth
head chef Richard has been given the
night off so I can show the Russian
owner Neil how strong the kitchen is
without it I think the team have done a
bloody good job but will Neil agreed
table 37 uh thought the food was
absolutely fantastic I'd like to uh come
down and meet you and the rest of the
team are they local or yeah
[Music]
thank you
I mean that well done you're responsible
for that food
Neil looks delighted but has he had the
bollocks to read Richard the ride act no
seriously guys it really was nice it was
absolutely beautiful you did what
tonight
Ariel did it intense good medicine we
all just kept swapping sections yeah
we're all right together as a team and
we all we all reading club together it
was great you let me down tonight
no we've done your pride I think I can't
work very well down there eventually
tonight for the first time in such a
long time I went and had a meal
that I can't complain about at all
[Music]
I can't
it [__] sex on a plate guys remember
you're my boys my girls at the end of
the end of the time mine
what I need to know in the next two days
what you're going to do in the shop
okay
if you want to go sit in a shop doing
[__] all for the rest of your life
to your decision
I said it was your decision when you won
you know the bookshop's good from a
degree I can get them a degree there
got me by the shop and Curly's there
sure
the team performed bloody well tonight
without Richard
and Neil should look really close at
that because that is a bad investment
and more than halfway through my week at
the Glass House the good news is the
kitchen team are doing really well last
night they cooked without their head
chef Richard and did a great job
oh Richard's still struggling I kneel
the owner isn't tough enough to get rid
of him plus do you think he takes
advantage of you because you're such a
nice guy to work with
sometimes yeah but then I think everyone
takes advantage of me he gets paid for
that amount of money yeah every month
and it's a bloody good salary but there
doesn't seem to be any onus on you know
evolving let's get better he's got to
make money
this is yours your livelihood your
family your money and if this goes yeah
then they won't bug it off and got a new
job I know that and you're sat here in
the [__] so you're taking a bit out of
the service yeah myself I've never put
Richard back in the kitchen without him
it's a happier place serving better food
but it's Neil's decision
she now realize how much time yeah the
guys I've got what I was saying to him
last night at the end of the day we are
a family and we've got to work it out
and the big inspiration I want them to
come on so this slides back down they'll
slide back down slide back down
okay my next challenge to relaunch the
menu by the end of the week so the Glass
House can start to win back its
customers maybe Richard will finally
show me he can run the kitchen as far as
I'm concerned it's his last chance for
the team it's another opportunity to
prove themselves yeah good and that's
the most important thing about being a
talented cook you know that having that
inner strength to turn around and say no
stop that's not good enough and what do
we talk about yesterday the state's
staying where in the kitchen every time
and the minute you break that Cardinals
rule when you start sending those
mistakes if you think the chef won't see
it yeah and like chain your ass you know
that yeah hi and um you know like you
said first step of the relaunch is to
cut down the menu you want to give a
little bit of twist on there and when I
went through the art the menus last
night late last night 85 to 90 dishes
yeah how on Earth we get to control that
you know over you know it's it's a lot
of a lot of gear on there and no I've
not actually sat down and counted it if
the menu is reduced and then we've got
six starters six main courses and five
six puddings we're going to sell more of
them yeah and so the more we sell of
them the cheaper it comes to make yeah
especially when we do the lamb shanks
yeah I personally don't want to see
Frozen but lovely in Brackets next to
chip if you don't put that then the
buggers turn around a gold it's a lovely
meal but I can't believe your chips were
frozen you're the only restaurant I've
ever ever come across that writes Frozen
but lovely hot fat
vegetables in it as well as reducing the
menu we have to make sure the food's top
quality that's the team's job
so we roast them
main course local lamb I've no doubt
Claire can improve on the fatty lamb
shank I had when I first had here
okay but I want it all the way around so
I'm just on the top hurry up then we're
gonna make some better puddings yeah the
bread and butter pudding they used to
serve here was pure starch my version
should be perfect for the new menu I put
Craig in charge of the recipe but the
God is up to it
[Music]
and my spies told me last week that we
didn't even wash this lettuce for season
salad and I don't want a hands in there
yet and addition they could become
famous for itself a classic Caesar salad
that's one for a year
look at the Contour of the plates going
around so putting the top part of the
salad around the outside of the plate
we're going to lightly glaze
the warm egg in the center
parmesan
crispy bacon and then nice crispy
croutons around the outside
there you go the new glass house
Caesar Salad Fingers on look
here wipe it
yeah a brand new menu and a fresh start
if all goes well tonight we'll see The
Glass House Reborn
[Music]
70 local people have been invited to try
the new food everything everywhere has
got to be just right and I mean right I
mean perfect
don't take this the wrong way yeah and I
mean don't take this wrong way last
night you had bad breath okay yeah and
when we're standing there talking to
customers and you're trying to sell them
something yeah it doesn't smell good
even Richard seems to realize the
importance of tonight's launch
[__] gonna work
yeah yeah let's screaming let's [__]
shout Chef when I call the checkout yeah
wait for the end of the chat yes chef
yes yes
looking at reducing the menu Richard and
having
um slashed the prices this is not an
expensive dish to put together is it not
no not at all I've designed the menu
especially for Richard everything's
cooked in advance so there's no chance
of a mistake and the haddock costs
absolutely nothing this morning was it
70 Pence a pound
yeah yeah and it smells lovely
sex on a spoon
um who have we got in uh that we know
tonight tabling of all the people
locally that have bnb's bed and
breakfast there's quite a few in the
media yeah I've got the one of the head
guys some tourism they want to contact
you so I'm gonna make yourself available
I'm gonna recharge my mobile
which I uh
turned off many months
Hallelujah Niels behaving like a
proprietor with balls proud of his
restaurant
he's even booked the guests in shifts so
there's less pressure on the kitchen
progress at last
we've just got everybody in by the eight
o'clock so we've got 25 minutes this is
easy hello we have never met
and in two minutes time our our Asylum
starts declare
yes if the kitchen's quiet everyone can
concentrate then it should be impossible
to confuse orders
[Music]
oh no come on Randall
Randall come here
we're supposed to work together on this
aren't you which is calling out orders
and you're tipping Cutlery upside down
get at least waitress Finish First no so
once he's finished talking to his
Brigade yes we can give him an answer oh
this lamb is definitely better off the
bone yeah
very very smooth so hopefully touchwood
the rest of the night it'll be even
better
let's swap tables you still have three
Caesar salad and one pressed ham
Richard's back in charge of the kitchen
there's only food to reheat and salad is
the dress
please
Ian's distro but it is Richard's job to
check everything before it leaves the
kitchen
[Music]
left making a lot of noise
he's not leading the team
[Music]
s 49 21 next orders are piling up again
we're looking bad not tonight please not
tonight
[__] sake
come on Randall quicker
five fish pies two three four five six
six total two at the front clap
don't really know what the hell's going
on in there but you know let me just say
for the last three or four minutes be in
there it looks shocked let's check on
Claire well tonight no don't go 49 yeah
you got the number they really have
managed to [__] it up properly again
and they don't have to cook anything
except dress the salad and talk to each
other they can't even do that so this is
a [__] embarrassment wait one second
listen yeah that's fine take one she's a
salad out please Richard yes
table number to 51. ratio 51 next I'm
not taking any prisoners anymore
seriously not
people don't pull away they're out of
here because I'm not [__] about
table 12. um what's that there for Rich
Neil may say he won't take prisoners but
surely you can see Richard can't cut it
but instead of plucking up the courage
to sacky Chef he moans about my Caesar
salad
not good at all
foreign
squash in the salad of the side of the
bowl and you're telling me that's too
big that is fresh salad beautifully
washed and I haven't even put my hands
in it to dress it I've let it dress
itself in the bowl so what you're
telling me is absolute bollocks and I'm
ready for a [__] argument right now
you're talking out your own argument if
you want an argument you're talking out
your ass
you're talking out your ass
oh really
amazing it's got big enough bollocks to
stand up to me but he can't tell his own
Chef who's paid 25 Grand a year at this
time he took his p425.
we survive the evening but only just I
shouldn't care but I do like these guys
and I want the place to be assessed
remember to fish pie here
I am so distorted with Richard tonight
you couldn't organize it couldn't
control it and you know what
he had nothing to bloody cook
[Music]
it's my last day at The Glass House hey
it's red tree time yeah how far is it
from here
about two minutes yeah the most
important thing now is to tell the real
workers they've done a great job I
didn't think I was actually capable of
doing this reach until he actually came
but now I think that I'm just starting
to get the hang of it and we will keep
the standards up because you've really
done done a lot for the kitchen and
you've done a lot for me personally as
well
you've done it for yourself all I've
done is drawn out I guess we'll put it
in here yeah yeah that's it that's
you've done it so you feel like today
when I had my little tone with myself I
just couldn't couldn't help but just
stand there and just go bloody hell this
is me
um
[Music]
you know
Randall gotta get some sleeping boy so
fired up he hasn't slept God maybe we
are related after all what would would
would say
you have a natural touch with food you
know that you walk around the kitchen
like a ballerina
just the way you position yourself
you're agile of your on your toes and I
still can't believe you've been cooking
for three months
because your strength over the last
seven days has been inspirational
I think I'm gonna sell my shop
and then get it
back into it
today I'm a really good chef
oh my God
Neil had a word well you guys ever word
every night after service what did he
say last night he gave me the options
three options and
to the third one
uh what were the options
what I want want to leave to Sega pay
cutner drop down the ladder and three to
stay worked my ass off develop the guys
carry on with what we've been doing over
the last few days and go for it are you
confident that you can become the new
glass house chef
yeah
truthfully how long will you give him
police officer
a month
yeah
just promise me one thing yeah
you make the [__] decision and you
stick to it I want more than anything in
my heart for Richard to prove me wrong
I hope he does
never let your mistakes leave your
kitchen
Randall I want you to hang that up with
a bit of pride and passion and I want
that to replace that disgusting dingy
horrible yellow smelly clock downstairs
[Music]
three months of pass since I've spent a
week at the Glass House Restaurant
trying to rescue it from disaster
menu looks nice nice and small
now I'm back to see what if anything has
changed hello Neil uh Mr Ramsey how are
you how are you good to see you yeah I'm
fine thank you yes yeah you look a lot
more relaxed yeah you look a little I I
you look happier I'm a different person
to the one that was here
to the first person you talked when you
came in and I'm completely I'm more
confident you know I mean you came in
and you highlighted things that I I kind
of knew that they were there but they
were buried in the back of my head you
know you brought them all to the
Forefront and and I'm glad you did that
but God what a week though I mean we
went through a rollercoaster
things were really Grim when I first
came here Sally I did and by Grim I mean
catastrophic that was
um stuck at the back of my throat but
however we're just calling out orders
and you're tipping Cutlery upside down
then I'm gonna clean your ass you know
that yeah not tonight please not tonight
the kitchen team came into their own
when I gave head chef Richard the night
off good good good good and blood is
good let me ask you you've got a pair of
bottles has it gone well without Richard
it's gone smooth
I'll die try you're talking about your
ass
I'll still stand by that and the big
question yeah
who's the chef Richard Richard is still
here yes he's downstairs he's downstairs
oh my God and he's nervous to him yeah
I'm right be nice morning guys
how are you Richard very well you're
welcome yeah one thing I have noticed
since I walked in um to the kitchen to
have these plastic containers start
creeping back out look all them along
there yeah they're back the new dishes
that you've involved
um and put on the menu while I we're
doing a talagio pomegranate risotto uh
which sounds intriguing so we've got a
crunchy pomegranate seeds yeah mixed in
risotto yeah sounds [__] revolting
oh [__] me
welcome back this is a new dish that we
put on tell me about it that's the puff
pastry
onion over there and we've got put goat
cheese on top of that nice to see
Craig's cooking
and we sold about seven when we put it
first off Ian what have you been doing
new and exciting to tell me uh got a
toffee fruit crumble on now toffee fruit
crumble yeah
with chrome fresh no you can't well that
sounds really nice
I thought Ian had real talent I'd give
him a job in one of my kitchens any day
and his girlfriend
and where's my sweetheart Claire where
where is she
uh she had a problem with selling the
shot I couldn't get out of it and uh she
comes out we can gives us a left at
weekends gives her hander
it's a shame she's a big loss
and my fellow Scott Randall he's gone
too sad
this is risotto with Palacio cheese
flat leaf parsley and pomegranate
be nice to win him over
Neil's hung in there but it can't have
been easy it's gone closer to the wire
than I've realized how close we to
closing the door
very close worst thing for me was like
not then I was paid the guys like one
stage I didn't I didn't think I'd be
able to pay them you know and I think
these guys they put the effort and they
put the Graft in they've done everything
there and they've always been behind you
um and it's like suddenly you can't put
any money in the pocket and it's been a
constant struggle but it's like now I'm
I can actually say to myself I'm going
to start reaping the rewards and I will
do you know and I'm a lot more positive
about it in fact January it's been
fantastic weekends have been busy you
know there is a difference in the food
you know presentation
just looks and Slick it tastes
you know tasty well thank you
still a bugger still not convinced about
my pomegranate risotto you know that's
another thing about that one on the
train on the way back because that yeah
that beats my [__] Eddie in that one
um it's been a pleasure today and
there's been of interest
um keep it up yes there's lots to
celebrate
turnovers up 20 and Rising the Russians
building a good reputation and going
from strength to strength you never know
Neil's nervous breakdown might never
happen when you come back just book on
someone else's name so yeah
yeah that's it now every bloody name
that box will be gone a guy sounding
funny on the phone you're telling you
it's Gordon
I really hope this succeeds and I really
hope they do well but any chef that
comes up with a risotto finished with
bloody pomegranates needs a kick up the
ass
again
pomegranates in a [__] risotto they
must be off their [__] rocker